par rapport à ces par rapport à marie va
ça vous embête au niveau magail qua non
de la signature tada l'auteur des faits
un petit focus on sera ta gueule tu
attends mais alors tu avais tout en
reconnaissant qu'ils croient être chaud
j'étais complètement
on a des photos et je ne sais pas dit
bonjour j'ai lu ni retombera ces voix là
4 elie semoun et bien su plus bien alors
elie semoun vous savez bien là j'ai très
bien qu'on me regardez moi dans les yeux
ok pas de ce fait comme si la personne
n'existe hélas personne n'existe pas
c'est pas peur ça n'existe pas c'est un
petit peu difficile bien savoir combien
de fois on vous dit que vous êtes
mignonne et tout lui dis jamais jamais
mieux on vient aussi quelqu'un minjan
non ma rivale est pas mignon de marie
van belle mareva voit la belle femme
belle femme c'est une belle femme fonder
une famille à elie semoun
oui parce que c'est vous beau succès
avec votre premier one man show elie
semoun mise en scène par votre amie
muriel robin quand j'ai rien à dire les
qui vous étiez dans les baladins de
l'avenue du toujours à c'était un
succulent sérieusement c'était un énorme
succès ce oui c'est vrai ouais
oui c'est vrai que ça c'est vrai je suis
content et d'équité dieudonné ouais il
ya des chanteurs moi j'y croyais mais il
ya des gens et vous le premier qu'il
sait comment ça va se passer
ouais et en fait ça marche encore mieux
qu'avec oui c'est vrai bien que je
regrette de plus être avec lui c'était
sympa mais bon c'est vrai que ça marche
ça marche bien alors actuellement à
l'affiché un film qui s'appelle deuxième
vie oui de la film de patrick braoudé
avec gad elmaleh tirer des remises et
bien d'accord voilà attendait là vous
allez prendre le cours de promo à la
télé ainsi prendre le coeur qui est
encore sur l'écran un sim que l'on pas
les voir dans toutes les salles de
cinéma moyennant
s'il te plait je suis parti sur ma
lancée une somme de 40 francs film où
l'on rigole si le moule on s'esclaffe
film où l'on l'eau frémir tous les
cinémas complet voilà mais voilà ça
c'est de la provoc prenez-en de la
graine
voilà c'est un film de patrick braoudé
qu'isabelle deuxième vie c'est
l'histoire d'un garçon qui s'appelle
vincent qui a 30 ans qui est incapable
de choisir dans la vie ce qu'il veut
faire
et un jour il a un accident de voiture
et se retrouve le destin choisi à sa
place ils se retrouvent pdg odieux avec
ses amis etc
mais c'était un film qui marche une idée
c'est très dangereux vide et qui va être
achetée par un américain
sûrement sûrement et puis
à
voilà ça s'appelle et lille annonce
semoun en sauce et le dvd c'est pour les
riches
photo sp lecteurs ça c'est pour nous
c'est à dire ce qu'on craint
magnétoscope voilà c'est la cassette qui
a comme star jahjaga d'iliad jamais n'y
d'armes au il ya cristiana reali y aller
robail à franck dubosc évidemment il ya
plein de gens n'y a pas qu'à des
oliviers et mareva il n'y a pas en
mission et vite douillet et c'est tout
ça pas plus